The question we're given asks
us, how many students attended
Einstein School in 2006?
And in this little table, they
tell us how many attended in
2001, 150 students, and in 2002,
225, 2003, we had 300
students, but they don't
tell us 2006.
So what I think they want us
to do is to see the pattern
and how many students the
population of students grew by
every year, and just assume that
that pattern continues
through 2006.
So we need to figure out what
the pattern is from one year
to the next, and then we're
going to figure out 2004,
2005, and then 2006.
So the assumption that we're
making in this problem, and I
think that the problem wants us
to make, is that whatever
the pattern of growth was in
these three years, that they
continue all the way to 2006.
So let's see what's
happening here.
When we go the first year, what
happens to our student
population?
We go from 150 to
225 students.
And the easiest pattern to think
about is, well just how
much are we increasing
by every year?
So how much do we have to
go to from 150 to 225?
We increased.
Well, if you increase by 50,
you get to 200, so we
increased another 25.
So we increased by
75 students.
And then they go from
225 to 300, how many
did we increase by?
Looks like 75 again.
75 plus 225 is 300.
So it looks like we increased
by another 75.
So the pattern here is that each
year, 75 more students
attend the Einstein School.
So let's just continue
that pattern.
So let's add another 75.
Let's add another 75
to the 300 in 2003,
and we'll get 375.
In 2004, if we assume the
pattern continues, let's add
another 75.
And then what will
that give us?
That'll give us 450 students
in 2005, if we assume the
pattern continues.
And we're almost there.
Let's add a final
75, 75 plus 450.
If you add 50, you get
to 500, so it's
another 25, so it's 525.
So that would be the answer to
our question, if we assume the
pattern continued, that 525
students attended Einstein
School in 2006.